who school school is back for a lot of
families right now it's coming back this
is the big weekend and thank you for
checking in this is the big last weekend
before school member remember the summer
was long you had summer camp and you
might have went through a little bit of
her buddy you know what one day you wake
up in your legs a little bit longer or
you got a little bit of hair on your
kneecaps or you got you know maybe you
get a little titty or something you wake
up in the morning and you got a little
kitty and you fell asleep
sands Conte you know without tit but you
wake up in the morning and your shirt
got a little bitter you know some of
your fat is kind of meeting up around
your nipple like they smoking a giant
like your nipple is like a brown junk
and some of your fat cells kind of met
up around it to hit to get that hit or
baby and that is a tit that's how at it
starts and Men we don't get them some
guys we've had we had a fella that got
some wild tits from Tennessee uh last
year and he got tattoos on him and
everything in but a lot of men don't get
up don't get titty you know a lot of men
don't get titty but it is school time
dude I went out when school was coming
and he got in that last week and summer
was wrapping up like about a week before
I would I would set my clothes out on my
bed I knew what I was wearing mom had
got us two outfits one of them you know
usually has some Shabo jeans or
something
and maybe a um a var net t-shirt or
something nice
I had my Eastlands them low top Eastland
hitters baby then foot boats baby them
shoes and I get them headers and lay
them out I later pants out I'd even roll
the pant legs up a little like I was as
if my body was on the ground I would lay
my whole outfit on the ground and look
at that [__]
and say damn that boy he looks and he's
gonna look nice and then I'd have my
outfit I'd have it all and man school
came fast man and you had your new
clothes do it in our first day at school
I get my hair fixed
oh I'll put everything in my hairdo I
shampoo it do i conditioner it then I
put a little damn you know I put some
musk powder in it I put a little gel I
put a little foam I put a little more in
it I do it all I put some baby powder
and the sighs boy case the ladies come
a-knockin
this head smell is rocking because look
a lot of ladies they want a baby that's
genetic if you throw a baby up in the
air and its little enough a lot of
ladies will catch it right there in that
word in there Virge it bro they'll catch
it in that that vid you know that vagina
net boy they'll just do it ah do a
headstand and what catch that BAM beem
because the ladies want that baby they
want it
dude if you if you put a LIF you put a
baby on rollerskates and send it by a
couple ladies they're gonna follow it
and that's 100% science or so you know
that's there's a lot of you got to know
what's up so that's the thing if you put
a little baby powder in your hair that's
the bait and switch they they smell that
baby and then BAM they get that man you
feel me they get you and that's what it
was on for my from everything went in my
hair first day of school dude I do
everything to get the ladies to come
around looking at that poivre baby
looking at that hitter baby that looking
at that freaking crisper I was a crisper
Potamus you feel me and everything went
in mine had a little bit of Cologne I'd
even take a hit off that Cologne if the
thing you know because some of that got
Ralph Lauren they used to have that
Ralph Lauren Cologne and that [__] was
probably about nine proof and I put a
little bit I pour you know pour dropping
each year and then just get that get a
little head in myself boy you drink
enough cologne your breath will smell
good for damn at least two seasons you
know come winter you just you just
easing off that positive scent you'd
have in you and man that first day you I
my hair had it oh my hair had it Oh
everything was in there I put all of
just trying to put a little ketchup
behind my ears anything to get the
ladies to look over at Popeye and it was
from him in the first day of school he
showed up
and no matter what I had on the outside
but you are all excited who's doing what
who's got a beard who's pregnant who
failed who didn't fail who moved away
all dang leonard moved away who was
Leonard I didn't even [__] know him
boy bye Leonard
somebody did this somebody did something
and you came back to school when you
found out all dang Patrick went to Texas
how was it you know little wad Jennifer
she caught a UH
she caught a a a couple charges she was
escorting outside 'adam a MP you're like
damn sorry Jennifer and what else little
love ldren got his oh he got corn road
damn love ldren that [__] looks tasty
everybody brought the tails from their
summer back you know somebody somebody
had a nice shirt they went to Florida
memmer net Florida ah you see they had
the shirt say Florida and that was the
real hit or somebody that went to
Florida like damn I mean Florida was our
moon you know Florida was really our
moon but huh there was no it was so
exciting but then also was so nervous
because every year that first day of
school was like Oh Cara the girls gonna
like me this year
you know what am I just gonna be too am
I gonna be as any girl gonna look at me
as him you know what's my vibe gonna be
Who am I and sometime I you know I come
to school and I had bad acne and acne is
just I mean your dick is so wiling and
yet when you're young your dick is just
such an animals trying to climb out of
your head from the inside of you I mean
while you're laying there at night your
dick will run up through your neck up to
your face and try to jump out of your
pores and your pores get all bruised
from the inside and that's acne and it
shows on the outside and they got a
little bit of bust and some of them got
a little bit of bus because that
I mean you just yeah your horror moans
is so vibrant your hormones they bought
you know they they Wilin and they try
you in you know and you dick just
scooting around inside of you tryin to
bust out of your face at night and
leaving little divots and stuff and
that's acne and that's another thing if
you start up with acne at school member
well broke my heart
dude coming to school you had a huge zit
on you
that thing was heavy some of them dude I
had acne so bad one time I remember
having one said it was kind of heavy on
the side of my face like damn I couldn't
even I had to have one of my buddies
kind of just pull down on my other ear
you know just to keep my head straight
because I had that heavy Zee baby that
big city that baked ziti on my side I
was fully Italian that you know that
little bust lump that acne that that
things trying to cuz you were just so
hard a member
remember how horny you were as a boy as
a child remember a noon hour
I remember we went to his funeral he was
erect in a coffin like damn damn
Wallis's he got that death bust enemy
trying to bust from beyond it was
different different time but I
remembered and I know a lot of your
parents have your kids going back to
school and just uh my thoughts are with
you because I know it's it's an exciting
time and you guys are looking for a
break it's probably been a long summer
out there and I remember my mom it was
risky every day she would leave the
house and who knows that that thing was
gonna be standing when she got home you
just a risk she just left a couple dang
risk of Potamus is just milling around
inside of the zoo that was our home when
she went to work in the summertime did
you enjoy that clip well you really
would have enjoyed it if he was watching
on a TCL TV TCL is America's fastest
growing TV brand it's so fast it's the
Carl Lewis of television brands it's
that Florence Griffith visual jointer
it's celebrating its fifth anniversary
from launching in the US markets I have
one of these at home and these suckers
are just I mean it's like having a Mona
Lisa on your wall that plays everything
you want follow TCL at TCL underscore
USA on Twitter and Instagram for more
details for more information about TCL
visit TCL usa.com
that's TCL usa.com